70 of divorces are initiated by women
but as a couple's therapist i've never
seen one divorce where the husband
didn't have attachment issues what do
attachment issues look like in a couple
one thing that i see a lot is trying to
earn approval by doing various things so
women with attachment issues use sex
with their partner to try to get
approval and love from that partner sex
becomes almost a performative act where
she's more focused on making sure he's
having the time of his life instead of
her having a mutual shared experience
with him as far as men it's built on
getting approval and specifically sexual
approval it's how can i get my wife to
have sex with me he may do 10 nice
things for her and he expects her to
respond with and be so thrilled that he
did the dishes and walked the dog and
took care of the kids that she is going
to suddenly become spontaneously aroused
and leap on him like a jungle predator
and when she doesn't when she's just
happy like hey cool you're holding on
the fort you're being a great partner
that's wonderful he gets angry he gets
set passive aggressive he says why isn't
she meeting my niece doesn't she care
about me